serverseitig hierzu lehrte kommt zu
einem neuen video heute zu meiner seite
ins 23 und insgesamt 20 und heute leute
stehen wir unser youtuber wissen auf dem
prüfstand wir haben den ultimativen
test- und zwar das youtuber content das
hat die schweiz informieren
da also youtube und verschiedenen
kategorien die abonnenten gesamte us-
anzahl videos kanalstadt und aufrufe
auch beliebt ist das video wir werden
heute mal sehen wie gut ihr ins kopf und
ins kopf mit youtube in deutschland
auskennt ich werde ja da die werte über
die katholischen und ihr versuch zu
erwarten wäre es ist aber vorher einfach
braucht ihr weiter wie immer noch ein
board also dass das gebäude war an bord
sein wird ich würde sagen dir denken
vielleicht etwas kurzes
desoxyribonukleinsäure was willst du
also max antwort 10 uhr wird er vor der
sortie ribonukleinsäure sagt ja dann
doch fast nie sagt ok fangen wir an
aufrufes beliebteste video bei der
ersten karte sind 50 4 millionen klicks
wer könnte das sein
der soziologe unsere bibliothek ist
kannst du auch war waren zufrieden
tatsächlich ist es baby mit 50 4 mio
auch von maxi karte wieder dicht die
will ich aber gar nicht okay der kanal
der nächsten karte wurde am 17 02 2012
gegründet
abonnenten 455 millionen wer könnte das
sein
also ist drin bleiben bei maxis gesagt
okay ich doch auf die karte kommt ihr so
schnell nicht abonnenten 1,89 millionen
inside gesamte views 370 millionen
bushido ok aufrufe auch beliebtestes
video 40 89 millionen in china
dann musste ich das so eine sache sagen
die karte auf der karte selbst nicht
steht es kann eventuell sein dass da
schon mal wenn ich jetzt sage müsse auch
kosmalla ist steinig das ist dem kanal
mal der ein oder andere vielleicht das
stadtgebiet hat ja viel wie konnte denn
einmal im hip hop mehr verfassen es ist
jonas heute ja daher würden die karten
spielen
die bei mir wirklich okay ich mache
weiter leute wir haben ungefähr
okay da kann ich sogar die aktuelle zahl
der cup steht eine geringere zahl aber
sind da lockte lediglich 1,1 milliarden
news 3 millionen astronomie aufrufe auf
passives video 4,13 millionen abonnenten
[Gelächter]
loukas louka hier übrigens lukas okay
leute ja na bist du am leben
okay wir schauen auf eine gesamtzeit von
videos von 10 1060 abonnenten 1160
videos insgesamt 10.000 videos hat der
arme der ein einzelner max willst du dir
nicht vielleicht überlegen zumindest das
passwort zu verwenden weil sonst einfach
nichts gesehen was du hast du über beide
einzigen karte max
nein
eine ganze warum hast du dir billiger
und hast das gold gesagt und danach
aufgehört das wort zu sagen ja nicht
verblödet verblödet okay nicht sein kann
wurde erstellt am 13 11 2010 und hat
seitdem
display ist ok so viel solltest du magst
du das ganze spiel prinzip also du
kannst du bitte das wort sei ein anderes
gilt überlege ich mir okay dann ist
kommen wir zum nächsten youtuber der hat
ungefähr 21 4 millionen abonnenten aber
nur 172 videos online den er hat auch
deutlich über drei millionen aufrufe
aufwändig ist das video 29,18 millionen
also man könnte als tipp an der stelle
noch hinzufügen dass die person 140
selbst programmiert dass sie einen
erhöhten grad an authentizität hat und
man könnte auch sagen das lassen wir es
ist nein ich bin nervös sein aber das
hänge ich bin da wenn ich sage nicht
sagen wahrscheinlich bin ich finde
sollte das ziel eins zu zehn
und ich fühle mich als wenn einem
behinderten kind